les bleus une nouvelle fois à l'honneur
aujourd'hui mais cette fois à l'elysée à
la traditionnelle garden party
l'ambiance était totalement au foot des
jacques chirac s'est affichée comme le
premier des supporters un président de
la république très modéré dans ses
critiques à l'égard du gouvernement
françois hollande sera le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste sera donc
notre invité dans ce journal pour
commenter ces propos de jacques chirac
et puis nous irons sur les champs
elysées le décrivent ce matin a été
particulièrement réussie même si on
était loin de la ferveur de ces derniers
jours autour de l'équipe de france
l'ambiance du tour de france elle est
empoisonnée par une affaire de dopage
tout le monde attend de voir quelles
seront les suites judiciaires de
l'affairé festina et puis nous irons au
champ-de-mars à paris où se prépare le
grand spectacle laser et pyrotechnique
de jean louis saez zar pour le 14
juillet sophie mais elle a assisté en
avant première aux répétitions
madame monsieur bonsoir il fallait s'y
attendre cette journée du 14 juillet a
été presque aussi folle que celles qui
l'ont précédée les bleus d'aimé jacquet
a été partout dans le coeur des
supporters et des badauds venus assister
au défilé officiel sur les champs
elysées et pendant la traditionnelle
garden party de l'elysée dont l'équipe
de france était l'invité d'honneur
l'elysée a donc vécu un 14 juillet
complètement foot je vous le disais
françois brabant et bruno livertout
stade de france lido 20 douche non
bienvenue à l'elysée temple des
institutions de notre belle république
mais elle à chaud la république en ce 14
juillet 1998 on peut même dire qu'on lui
a mis le feu on sait l'équipe de france
ils sont tellement fiers d'avoir réussi
notre pari qu on vous le donne cette
nous voulons vous appartient même les
militaires ont craqué trois mille jeunes
environ venus de toute la france ont
transformé cette garden party en joyeuse
ternel moitié troisième mi-temps moitié
concert rock
en tout cas 100% spectacle céline
moi je voulais tester simplement dire
que vous remercie de votre soutien qui
fait tout le soutien que vous avez porté
contre toute cette coupe du monde et
maintenant elle est là au moins pour
quatre ans donc on va la garder et on va
faire encore la fête très longtemps mais
merci merci à tout le monde pour faire
honneur aux invités d'honneur tout le
monde est sur une même pelouse
les mocassins et les baskets mais la
tendance vestimentaire est nettement
sport cette année et les préoccupations
aussi pourquoi alors les joueurs chirac
joie non plus les jours et pendant que
les mordus tueur tout prévu guette un
dernier autographes
on se déchaîne dans les jardins
présidentielle en la coupe du monde plus
fête nationale ça réconcilie avec la
politique
les politiques sont bien sûr mis à
l'heure des bleus et de la jacquet
manière à commencer par jacques chirac
leurs plus fervents admirateurs on
l'avait vu en écharpe de supporters au
stade de france cette fois ils étaient
tous footix la mascotte de la coupe du
monde qu'il arborait fièrement sur son
costume un cadeau a dit at il dit de
michel platini
le reportage politico sportif de
véronique saint olive et bruno livertout
de mémoire de république et on n'avait
jamais vu ça
l'élysée en folie
et le président de la république lui
même si la nuit tombe selon lequel salué
au nom du bon moment en mon nom est
longue et tout en france tous les jeunes
elle je le fais un cadeau le plus beau
cadeau peut puiser mais n'explique pas
elle faisait pas forcément
et c'est la coupe des lignes jacques
chirac et lionel jospin sont côte à côte
la cohabitation se déchaîne mais c'est
le président de la république qui gère
la situation
le service d'ordre est complètement
dépassé jacques chirac se noie dans la
ferveur et dans l'enthousiasmé il sait
qu'au delà de la signification sportive
de l'événement
cette communion avec la france toute
entière c'est aussi pain béni pour lui
mais c'est la course aux photos et aux
autres à cette fois les hommes
politiques sont demandeurs le monde à
l'envers
j'aime et j'étais sûr robert pires
je m'embarquais
je me tiens enfin c'est quand même pas
mal
j'avais donné davantage
sur la pelouse toutes étiquettes
confondues on tire déjà les premières
conséquences politiques
je pense que c'est avec percussions
nationale
les chansons entendues
et bah de l'ambiance de la confiance en
soi chaque responsable qu'ils soient
politiques qu'ils soient de quelques
situations de vie publique à à réfléchir
sur la façon dont il doit continuer de
porter cette dynamique et les
conséquences en sont épatantes parce
qu'on a montré qu'en fait la france est
une nation unie sans distinction entre
les uns les autres
aujourd'hui personne ne boude et son
plaisir
mais une fois la fête finie yves le
premier ministre et le président de la
république continueront peut de se
marquer voire de ce tacle et
selon m m le mettre le feu jacques
chirac a dans ses eaux bleues qu'il les
ferait chevalier de la légion d'honneur
pour aimé jacquet c'est déjà fait il se
trouve dans la promotion traditionnelle
du 14 juillet publiée aujourd'hui aux
côtés de michel platini promu officier
aimé jacquet auquel jacques chirac a
rendu un hommage appuyé 10h de lui qu'il
était un homme chaleureux fermés qu'il
incarnait le français dans ce qu'il a de
meilleur
un peu plus tôt sur les champs-elysées
il y avait bien sûr eu le défilé
militaire ordonnance et au millimètre
ils étaient cent cinquante mille à
s'être déplacé une nouvelle fois sur les
champs pour y assister
mais parmi ces bateaux beaucoup encore
porter leurs couleurs de supporters
patrick fandio et jeanne grégoire comme
pour prolonger le client fait aux bleus
sur cette même avenue certains
semblaient ce matin n'avoir pas quitté
les champs elysées depuis la victoire
et trois jours de suite que tous les
matins je fais mes peintures je ne sais
quelle femme est partie des modes la
france et champion du monde
nul n'est censé l'ignorer ce 14 juillet
d'autant plus que le défilé a attiré un
public plutôt habitué des stades pour la
finale
la coupe du monde dimanche et on en
profite d'entraînement tard
le début attendu avant à partir chez
loupe
ces trois jours de fête non stop alors
toujours entre dimanche et hier
aujourd'hui avec joubert avec l'armée
autre conséquence de l'effet mondial
même la très lointaine télévision
sud-coréenne avait dépêché une envoyée
spéciale sur les champs elysées c'est la
fête pour tout le monde
en france ils ont fait les autres pays
mais nous la corée les bleus avaient
réuni plus d'un million de personnes sur
les champs ce matin ils n'étaient que
150 milles
mais l'enthousiasmé était là ça remonte
le moral des français comme le football
remonte le moral des gènes et des
protéines est normal et tant que ça
continue il faut pérennité le le bleu
blanc rouge il faut qu'ça dure pour le
coq soit là en tout cas nul doute ce
matin c'était toujours les bleus qui
avait la vedette alors côté défilé
officiel maintenant quatre mille hommes
et femmes à pied 1500 autres sur
différents véhicules motos chevaux ont
descendu les champs dans un ordre
impeccable à la minute près françois
korber sachant qu'un légionnaire marche
à 90 par minute
qu'un cheval de la garde républicaine
37km eu qu'un blindé roule à 28 km heure
et qu'un mirage vol à 500 km heure au
dessus des champs elysées on comprend
mieux la minutie nécessaires à la
préparation d'un défilé de 14 juillet
ouvert comme à l'accoutumée par les
fumigènes tricolore de la patrouille de
france
quatre mille hommes et femmes à pied
quelque 90 avions et hélicoptères
une centaine de motos 270 chevaux et 15
cents hommes à bord de 300 blindé a pas
les régler à la seconde près pour une
durée d'une soixantaine de minutes de
l'étoile à la concorde un défi des
montées comme une véritable opération
militaire et qui avait pour thème cette
année une force de projection
interarmées mettant particulièrement en
vedette les gendarmes et des marsouins
une unité de la gendarmerie prévôtale
notamment qui accompagnent les armées
françaises dans les opérations
extérieures comme dans le golfe ou en
bosnie et la 9e division d'infanterie de
marine qui par son histoire et la
compétence de ces hommes est dédié à
l'outre-mer et aux opérations
extérieures
particulièrement remarquée dans ce
défilé les femmes plus nombreuses que
d'habitude
reflet de la féminisation des armées
mais aussi de la police à l'honneur l
océan ce 14 juillet 98 tout comme les
sapeurs pompiers de paris
une présence plus traditionnels sur les
champs elysées une armée en pleine
mutation
en route vers la professionnalisation
en ce corner viens de vous le dire
l'heure est donc à la
professionnalisation lionel jospin a
annoncé qu'elle se poursuivait
conformément aux engagements et jacques
chirac a salué cette volonté de réforme
l'armée elle s'adapte comme elle peut à
cette mutation en 2002 il n'y aura plus
de conscrits alors il faut tu engages
richard binet et roger mathurin monsieur
brandi ni vous avez été retenu pour le
4e régiment de chasseurs qui se trouve à
gap ce pourrait être un entretien
d'embauché ordinaire s'il n'y avait les
galons de l'officier recruteurs et comme
dans toute entreprise lorsqu'on est
engagé on signe il est encore en civil
il portera l'uniforme de 1 et demain
c'est l'an 2000 la fin du service
militaire l'armée recrute au pas de
charge
quinze mille hommes par an les jeunes
soient tirées par le terme de métier de
métier militaire à l'armée offre
vraiment une opportunité
c'est à dire à travers ces contrats
éventuellement à travers une carrière
levée des couleurs ou 4e chasseurs le
régiment blindé de la division
d'affronter de gains mille hommes
un sur cinq est déjà impressionnant
le chef de corps c'est le colonel cheikh
sonne on l'appelle le patron 25 ans de
carrière il dirige son régiment comme un
chef d'entreprise
fini le muscle et du militaire de
carrière si les minutes sont toujours
rasé un bon soldat ou avoir une tête
bien faite que certains ont dit les
militaires engagées pourraient être ceux
qui ne trouvent pas du travail
l'entv c'est inverse nous débouchons
quelquefois des gens qui ont un emploi
en civil
le quatrième chasseurs ses 36 blindé
qu'il faut entretenir un travail de
technicien
la plupart de ces jeunes ont un ca paix
ou un bep de mécanique
ils ont choisi l'armée comme une
entreprise parmi deux autres 5500 francs
par mois pour un premier emploi
nourri logé blanchi cela crée des
vocations je cherchais une machine rodée
qui fonctionne un atelier de comme
beaucoup de petites entreprises qui sait
plus de l'artisanat que la mécanique
pure puisque de mon domaine c'est le mec
années et j'ai pris un contre à trois
ans ce qui permet de voir et pour
l'instant je suis complètement satisfait
au dessus de gap le troisième blindés en
manoeuvre le premier escadron totalement
professionnaliser du régiment
à son commandement le capitaine
courrèges 29 en maths sup maths spé
saint cyr la voie royale pour un
militaire il est bien évident qu'avec un
service national qui n'a duré que dix
mois et dans une armée de plus en plus
technologique
on ne nous laissez pas la possibilité de
faire acquérir à nos jeunes appelés
l'expérience professionnelle la plus
importante qui soit aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui avec des personnes qui vont
nous dur et je veux rester avec nous
entre 5 10 15 ou 20 ans il est clair que
nous pouvons faire un travail de fond et
leur permettre d'acquérir toute la
connaissance des matériels qui sont bien
leur disposition
un char dans les rues de gap cela ne
choque plus personne au contraire on
s'en félicite
un régiment professionnaliser ses deux
fois et demi le poids économique
la régiment d'appeler ses 1000 milles
personnes qui vont travailler vivre dans
ce pays
c'est nos écoles qu'ils se rempliront
que ce sont les filles de ce pays qui
vont se retrouver avec des jeunes hommes
qui se marieront qui créeront des foyers
s'est ensuite des gens qui sont
professionnalisés et pour nos
entreprises c'est un personnel de grande
qualité qui pour que nous pourrons
intégrer
en 2002 le 4e régiment aura achevé sa
professionnalisation
il y aura toujours deux vieilles dames
pour saluer les militaires des petites
filles pour regarder passer les blindés
à ceci près qu'elle appellerons papa
leurs conducteurs
alors revenons en maintenant l aspect
plus politique des choses avec bien sûr
l'interview de jacques chirac le
président la république répondait aux
questions d'arlette chabot et de patrick
poivre d'arvor contrairement à l'an
dernier où ils avaient attaqué lionel
jospin a cette fois les critiques se
sont fait beaucoup plus légères jacques
chirac se situant délibérément au dessus
du quotidien du côté de la france qui se
transcende
il ne peut il ne doit pas y avoir de
tiraillements dans la cohabitation a dit
le chef de l'état et il en a fait la
démonstration à quelques exceptions près
le gouvernement a sa responsabilité mais
il faut savoir que dans le domaine
économique notamment l'international
il ya c'est comme un grand paquebot ça
ne vire pas comme une barque et par
conséquent la situation que nous
connaissons actuellement est due pour
une bonne part et à l'assainissement des
finances publiques et des lui le fruit
des efforts
les gouvernements précédents il ne faut
tout de même pas l'oublier j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire au premier ministre
que je trouvais que son jugement et est
injustement sévère l'égard du plan juppé
qu'en réalité c'est parce que depuis un
an on n'a pas fait en sorte que ce qu'il
prévoyait soit mis en oeuvre
sérieusement que nous nous trouvons
après cette immobilité en quelque sorte
ou en partie et nous nous trouvons dans
une situation de dérapage à nouveau des
dépenses qui vont exiger de nouvelles
mesures je persiste à penser qu' il est
très difficile d'appliquer ce genre de
règles de façon uniforme et total sous
forme de couperet et que s'ils n'ont mis
sur les 35 heures que nos missions
digitimes et
elle devrait être laissé pour ce qui
concerne sa mise en oeuvre à
l'appréciation des négociations locales
jeudi l'entreprise par entreprise
chaque fois qu'il ya un changement de
gouvernement nous avons un changement
des lois
ça c'est typiquement français est alors
naturellement ça envoie des signaux
contradictoires et très mauvais parce
que les gens sont patients encouragé à
venir chez nous ils se disent ah quand
les gens sont au pouvoir alors c'est
plus facile aux menaces précipitées et
quand nous ment ce sont des débats
stériles tout à fait stérile et il faut
avoir une réglementation et s'y tenir et
à mon avis cette réglementation doit
être ferme
il est nécessaire d'avoir une harmonie
dans nos institutions
parce qu'elles sont ainsi une harmonie
complète entre l'opposition et le
président de la république qui est issu
de ses rangs
de même qu'il doit y avoir un marmot ni
entre la majorité et le président de la
république lorsqu'il est issu de ses
rangs
alors gérard leclerc on le voit à
travers ces extraits la position du chef
de l'état s'est assoupli il rend même
hommage par moments à certains aspects
de la politique du gouvernement
oui en fait jacques chirac que devait
résoudre une contradiction ont profité
de la traditionnelle intervention du 14
juillet pour marquer ses différences
avec le gouvernement mais sans remettre
en cause le climat qu'on sent seul et
même euphorique créé par le mondial de
football
alors les envolées les superlatifs ont
été réservées à la vague bleue de la
coupe du monde sur laquelle la surfer le
président en appelant les français à la
confiance et la cohésion dans un pays
moderne où l'on gagne ensemble
il eût été difficile après ça d'attaquer
de front le gouvernement d'ailleurs les
sondages au zénith pour lui et le
premier ministre rendait la tâche ardue
la politique gouvernementale a donc été
passé en revue sans agressivité mezzo
voce avec eux mêmes quelques bons points
pour la sécurité on est je cite sur le
bon chemin ou pour la féminisation de la
vie politique certain succès ont tout
juste été relativisée si la croissance
revient c'est aussi grâce à l'action des
gouvernements précédents
si l'emploi s'améliore ce n'est pas le
cas pour les chômeurs de longue durée
le président a aussi prodigué quelques
comptes
cei en forme de mise en garde sur
l'immigration où la réglementation doit
être ferme ou sur la famille qui doit
être aidé plus explicite encore quelques
piques sur le sur la pression fiscale
excessive les dérapages de la sécurité
sociale parce que le gouvernement n'a
pas appliqué le plan juppé ou les 35
heures assimilé à un couperet mais signe
révélateur l'opposition a également eu
droit à ces rappels à l'ordre
une opposition qui n'est pas assez unie
et pas assez en harmonie avec le
président de la république un président
qui s'ils souhaitent une cohabitation
constructive n'a pas pu garantir qu'elle
irait jusqu'à son terme merci jean
françois hollande bonsoir vous êtes le
secrétaire du parti socialiste
alors on l'a vu sur les images au début
du journal on a vu jacques chirac très
entouré très capitaine presque 2 de
l'équipe de france et on se demande
presque y est le chef alors le patron de
l'équipe france et qui sait jacques
chirac ou céline jospin où elle pouvait
avoir ce sentiment vous pouvez même
imaginer qu'il avait marqué les deux
premiers buts mais sans les deux ans est
évident de la neige en été
si je puis dire rassurer mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas désagréable on va pas ici
bouder notre plaisir c'est passé que
désagréable d'avoir cautionné réplique
premiers supporters de l'équipe de
france qu'elle avait beaucoup d'autres
mais qu'il le soit je trouve que c'était
plutôt une bonne image générale mais il
ya une stratégie des politiques en temps
médiatique vis-à-vis d'une victoire
comme celle-là on a vu lionel jospin au
stade on a eu jacques chirac on a
analysé un petit peu leur attitude
respectives je crois d'abord que je
connais moins jacques chirac que lionel
jospin donc je peux parler davantage du
premier mise
je crois que il aime le football nous
sommes un certain nombre à aimer le
football c'est quand même un événement
historique que la france organise une
coupe du monde c'est un deuxième
événement historique que la france gagne
une coupe du monde et moi je trouve que
c'est bien qu'il y ait dans tout le pays
ja lire de des citoyens jusqu'au chef de
l'état un engouement pour une
organisation comme celle là qui était
parfaite et pour une équipe comme celle
là qui a été excellente et je crois
qu'il ya toujours des grincheux qui
trouvent que on en fait trop
il ya un peu d'excès ya toujours de
l'excès et je pense que il ya un moment
qu est un moment privilégié qui est
celui d'un pays à l'unisson avec un
succès on n'a pas énormément de succès
donc celui-là est majeur il pense
pourquoi s'en priver même si certains
doivent penser à quelques récupère son
bien
j'espère qu'on reviendra sur les
conséquences après maintenant sur le
fond du discours il ya eu des satisfecit
décerné par jacques chirac au
gouvernement je suppose que ça vous a
fait plaisir
il ya aussi des critiques appel à peine
voilé sur la fiscalité qui trop lourde
sur des choses comme ça soit 35 heures
qui sont adoptés être de façon trop
uniforme
vous l'avez senti comment le président
je l' ai sentis impressionné par à la
fois le climat d'euphorie du moment
grâce à l'équipe de france qui a donc
plein de mérite
et puis aussi impressionné par le bilan
d'un an de gouvernement parce que le 14
juillet dernier le chef de l'état
n'avait pas de mots assez durs pour
stigmatiser une action qui n'avait à
peine commencé aujourd'hui
un an plus tard il est plutôt dans le
domaine de l'e steam ou de la
reconnaissance
il admet en tout cas que ce gouvernement
est en train de réussir sur le chômage
sur la reprise économique
même sur la sécurité ils ajoutent
l'éducation écoutez moi je ne vais pas
m'en plaindre si le prix en avril malgré
lucidité conscience que ce gouvernement
réussit lorsque les précédents échoué je
ne vais pas ici là encore bouder mon
plaisir
il ya comme une critique a notamment
visé sur le plan le plan juppé dont il
dit que le développement était trop
sévère en leur n'appliquant pas il n'est
pas quand même pas tout à fait d'accord
avec vous quand même pas un président de
gauche qu'on a en france
oh non je vous rassure sur ce point il
est chef de l'opposition aussi on y
reviendra
mais il est aussi critique mais quand ça
fonctionne dans un pays quand ça marche
s'il ya encore beaucoup à faire même si
les résultats ne sont que provisoires à
voir dans les prochains mois dans les
prochaines années
comment voulez vous même si on est chef
d'état allait contre l'évidence alors il
a donné à rim de points critiques parce
que vous avez cité le plan juppé c'est
vrai que jacques chirac voulait que ce
plan juppé s'applique même au delà de
juppé d'assez normal que lionel josse
pas que les socialistes que la gauche
lorsque alain juppé décrit l'ancien
maire est parti très bien aujourd'hui ne
reflètent pas nécessairement le poche
poubelle parce que précisément le plan
juppé d'abord a été sanctionné par les
tribunaux sanctionner aussi par les
praticiens et qui n'était pas facile
d'introduire une maîtrise de la dépense
de santé dans ce contexte là mais je
gêne mais si vous voulez qu'il y ait de
temps en temps une critique lorsqu'elle
veulent et je pense que c'est bien dans
une démocratie que tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord que jacques chirac est
nostalgique d'alain juppé je pense que
ça rassure à au moins la jupe et plus
généralement une journée comme
aujourd'hui tout semble aller
parfaitement pour vous dit vous allez
affronter le gouvernement ceux ci étant
en particulier la croissance repart la
france gagne la coupe du monde on a même
appris aujourd'hui qui aurait pas de
poursuites contre eux de jasmin pour son
emplois supposés fictifs au ministère
des affaires étrangères de la plainte
n'a pas été retenu qu'est ce qui
pourrait vous arriver de grave je crois
qu est ce qui vous arrive est grave
c'est tombé précisément dans l'euphorie
l'autosatisfaction il ya un moment de
grâce c'est celui que nous vivons grâce
à un événement sportif
mais ce moment va passer comme tout
moment même de bonheur donc il faudrait
pas que dans quelques semaines dans
quelques mois les français après être
monté si haut se retrouve avec un moral
plus bas donc c'est la tâche de la
majorité est et vigilant lui disent ne
pas s'endormir sur nos lauriers ne pas
croire que la cohabitation n'est qu'une
cohabitation de velours il y aura des
moments plus difficiles
mais faire comme d'autres l'ont fait
pour compris les événements sportifs
travail et je crois qu'à pas d'autres
morale finalement que celle du travail
avec le souci de l'autre
avec aussi la solidarité ça vaut pour
les équipes de france savent de football
ça peut valoir aussi pour les équipes de
france au gouvernement alors vraiment
revenir sur une des sites de des
conséquences de cette victoire dont on a
beaucoup parlé jacques chirac a parlé
d'une d'une équipe tricolore et
multicolore et cette victoire donc
pourrait avoir des conséquences sur la
façon dont l'intégration est perçu dans
les quartiers et donc vincent fourcade
et mène faysal se sont en vue dans l'une
de ces cités qu'on dit un problème près
de du stade de france
et vous allez voir que là bas les
victoires de zidane djorkaeff de
karembeu et desailly ont une
signification très particulière
zidane buts 48 heures après la victoire
les gamins de l'union sportive du
quartier plein à saint denis
refont le match minute après minute une
nouvelle fois les tête de zidane
l'échappée d'emmanuel petit autant de
souvenirs en or mais pour les plus âgés
de cette banlieue du nord de paris
la victoire de l'équipe de france
représente bien plus qu'un événement
sportif
mokhtar nordine et nafa ont vibré pour
une équipe de france dans laquelle ils
se reconnaissent en droit dans l'équipe
de france qui a beaucoup il ya beaucoup
de joueurs d'origine étrangère
si t'arrives d'algérie thuram guadeloupe
de saïd du canada il ya plein et c'est
ça qui devrait quitter la porte et qu'il
pense à quelqu'un que j'ai réussi
cependant peu comme dans tout bon peu
comme zidane ou thuram pour qu'il soit
en france et voilà qu'on sera respectée
mieux respectés et mieux vaut mieux vu
voilà et ça donne des exemples pour les
jeunes pour les jeunes ya plus de noirs
et appelant maintenant c'est les
français qui ont gagné quand on cite a
dit marc sait pas c'est pas le l'arabe
qui a marqué ou sept français zidane
henry thuram ont fait leurs premiers pas
en banlieue alors pourquoi pas un jour
mokhtar et ses amis les autres retombées
de ce mondial sont bien sûr les
retombées économiques qu'elles sont
elles en terme financier après ce
mondial dont chacun souligné la très
bonne organisation
l'enquète de pascal golomer et d'alice
métiers d'art
40 milliards de téléspectateurs dans le
monde audience cumulée tout au long de
l'épreuve
record absolu et chaînes de télévision
françaises font partie des grands
gagnants qui dit record d'audience des
recettes publicitaires en hausse avec
des annonceurs et des sponsors ravi
d'avoir couché la suite du très large
en france c'est nouveau la france se
place dans le haut niveau du troisième
rang c'est le troisième pays qu'est le
plus regardé des matches de la coupe du
monde juste derrière la hollande et
l'angleterre mais loin devant de grandes
nations comme l'allemagne l'italie
l'espagne sont des grandes nations de
football et qu'ils ont au moins regarder
les matchs que les français cinq cent
mille supporters étrangers sont venus en
france 500 mille consommateurs
potentiels
mais dans le même temps les touristes
traditionnels sont venus moins nombreux
les restaurants les salles de spectacle
les cinémas ont perdu une partie de leur
clientèle habituelle
la fréquentation hôtelière aussi est en
recul -1 10% à paris par exemple avec
des nuances
sur les 4 étoiles et 4 étoiles luxe la
fréquentation
les taux de remplissage mais les
recettes sont bons
sur les 2 étoiles où les une étoile par
exemple est nettement moins bon il ya
des baisses de moins
25 300 millions de francs c'est le
bénéfice annoncé pour le comité
d'organisation
de quoi financer plusieurs actions liées
au football en direction des jeunes
mais quelle sera l'influencé de la coupe
du monde sur l'économie nationale
certes les ventes de télévisions sont en
hausse de 30% depuis le début de l'année
pour le reste les économistes préfèrent
rester prudents
aujourd'hui en france on a effectivement
des impacts très visibles sur certains
secteurs mais dans un cadre de
croissance assez bonne et il sera opéré
aujourd'hui impossible et il ne saura
sans doute impossible demain à travers
les chiffres de voir un effet spécifique
liée à la coupe du monde
c'est en tout cas une très belle
opération de promotion que la france
s'est offerte à destination du monde
entier avec la complicité de milliers de
journalistes étrangers
les bleus décidément s'était installé
sur les champs elysées pendant ces trois
jours hier soir la soirée a été longue
et chaude au lido pascal deschamps et et
régis matin ils sont encore plusieurs
centaines à les attendre grandi mais
c'est brill comme s'il ne voulait se
résoudre à les perdre pour la nuit on
les a vus à la télé sur les champs
elysées maintenant on a d'autres
exigences
embrasser le train de barthez ce sera
pour une autre fois
ainsi en a décidé la préfecture c'est
par la porte dérobée une entrée des
artistes qui leur va comme les grands
gardiens de but que quelques-uns des 22
sur leur 31
douchez mais encore un sommet arrive
l'un après l'autre
sous le regard illuminé de quelques
supporters peu débrouillard et parlez
vous qui a réussi à toucher la coupe du
monde
non non il sera plus facilement dieu que
ce soir là il faut bien le dire le
spectacle sont une éternité
sitôt les lumières allumées les costumes
cravates se lâche et les objets du culte
qui s'attendaient à une soirée
tranquille accepte gentiment les
dernières marques de dévotion d'un
public qui a soutenu leur aurait offert
la plus longue et la plus belle des
journées c'est géant voilà j'ai un petit
peu mou parce que ce n'est pas fini par
être fatigués nous aussi mais c'est vrai
que c'est sensationnel c'est tellement
tellement tellement de deux sourires des
sourires d'enfants de femmes qui eux
aussi ont découvert cette fièvre du
football
effectivement c'est merveilleux dernière
photo au milieu des gunners
zidane en haut à gauche portait mieux le
maillot que le boa il n'est que minuit
un autre public dans un autre night club
attend sa dose elle procure à ses
puissance rare et grisante que l'on
ressent au contact des présidents de
voir des supporteurs thriller a moins
mais on sent les héros fatigués comme il
est dur de l'équité comme il est dur de
les laisser retourner à leur intimité
quant au rêve de refaire avec eux un
verre à la main le film dépasse le film
débute et de la victoire
aller au brésil bien sûr l'ambiance
n'était pas la même on l'a vu avec les
reportages de christophe duchiron tout
séjour et on l'a encore constaté avec le
retour de l'équipe brésilienne
aujourd'hui un retour presque discret
are you où tout le monde s'inquiète de
l'état de santé de ronaldo que l'on a vu
ici boitillant sur le tarmac
mais les joueurs ont quand même été
reçus et décoré par le président
brésilien de là mais rien à voir avec
les les coupes du monde précédentes et
pour cause avant de refermer cette page
sur à la fois 14 juillet le mondial on a
appris un instant que l'une des
personnes qui avaient été blessés la
nuit de la coupe du monde sur les champs
elysées par une autre musique avec le
contrôle de sa voiture est bien l'une de
ces personnes est décédé là
l'automobiliste
elle a été transférée dans une clinique
psychiatrique et puis à propos de
l'agression dont a été victime le
gendarme nivelles de nouveaux hooligans
allemands sont en ce moment en garde à
vue enfin je voudrais vous signaler à
une performance de d'édiction plutôt de
publication avec à la fois la sortie
d'un livre souvenir sur la coupe du
monde que vous allez voir à l'antenne et
puis la magazine souvenir également deux
ouvrages que vous trouverez bien sûr
dans toutes les bonnes librairies voilà
trois jours à peine après l'exploit et
bien les deux premiers ouvrages sortent
déjà l'autre grand dossier du jour c'est
le tour de france avec une première
étape française entre roscoff et
lorgnant une étape remportée par
l'allemand et mère des télécoms au
classement général c'est maintenant le
danois hamburgers et endosse le maillot
jaune
voilà l'arrivée de cette troisième étape
du tout et première étape en france
après la balade irlandaise
mais sur le tour vous le savez on ne
parle en fait que d'une chose de la
sphère des festina autrement dit de ce
soigneur de l'équipe festina arrêté à la
frontière belge avec une quantité
importante d'anabolisants et de produits
dopants l'homme qui est le masseur
attitré de richard virenque et affirmé
qu'il avait agi sur ordre des
responsables de son équipe olivier
caroff et ipod ou s'expliquer au plus
vite devant les policiers ou un juge
d'instruction
c'est depuis ce matin le souhait le plus
cher de bruno roussel le directeur
sportif de festina la direction de
l'équipe cycliste aurait donné l'ordre
d'acheter et de transporter des produits
dopants
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme un
soigneur de festina un homme pris en
flagrant délit la semaine dernière et
aussitôt incarcéré de la faire je
demande à être entendu à la police parce
que je pense qu'il est temps que pour
nous les choses avancent vite et
s'éclaircissent s'il s'avère qu'il ya
des substances interdites dans le
véhicule qui a été saisi
cela s'est fait absolument à l'insu de
la direction de l'équipe festina
c'est dans une voiture aussi peu
discrète que celle ci que le soigneur
arrêté comptait rejoindre son équipe
à bord les enquêteurs ont trouvé des
centaines de flacons de substances
illicites
surtout des produits indétectables aux
contrôles antidopage
parallèlement une perquisition a été
menée au siège de festina dans la
banlieue de lyon pour certains coureurs
de l'équipe
vie libre est le soigneur est le seul
responsable possible chez festina il
était là et j'ai pas juger ce qu'il a
fait une erreur est humaine tout le
monde a droit de faire des erreurs mais
c'est pas parce qu'il a fait une bêtise
là qu'on doit les mettre la tête sous
l'eau je crois que il doit regretter ce
qu'il a fait
et il a mis tout le monde dans la
baraque à commencer par richard virenque
l'un des favoris de l'équipe vit niveau
est était son soigneur personnel après
l'arrivée visage fermé et amertume à
peine contenue et chats ou les pâtes une
nuit sereine à l'hôtel s'est bien passé
le feuilleton est t elle
chez festina tous attendent désormais de
savoir quand la justice jugera utile
pour l'anc est d'entendre les
responsables de licques alors qu'elles
étaient les produits que transporter ce
soigneur pouvait-il être utilisé par des
coureurs cyclistes
le médecin des festina donc déjà fait
savoir qu'il n'en était pas question
tout cela ce sera bien sûr à lenquête de
le déterminer
mais christelle bertrand nous fournit
déjà des explications
le stock de produits saisis jeudi
dernier par les douanes françaises
contenait deux sortes de dopant de le
pays et des anabolisants
le pe est une hormone qui stimule la
fabrication des globules rouges et plus
on a de globules rouges plus on est
endurant les anabolisants augmente la
masse musculaire devenir plus fort plus
longtemps dans une compétition qui dure
plusieurs semaines
ça aide forcément tous les sports serait
touché au bout du compte le corps et la
santé ne s'en sortent jamais indemne
j'ai eu très peur puisque mon foie quand
même a été légèrement touché meira aussi
puisque jury n'est salé vers l'orangé
rouge
je suis allé voir un médecin personnel
qui savaient que je me dopais est ce que
je me voyais dans le temps et qui lui
avait rien faire puisque c'est pas chez
lui puis je me fournissait me dise et
sait où tu arrêtes ou alors tu pas
carrément carrément suicides en france
ces produits sont interdits donc cher
ils proviennent de belgique de suisse ou
d'espagne en allant les douanes
françaises ont saisi 100 mille gélules
de produits illicites destiné aux taux
pages aux états unis ce marché
représente 4 milliards de francs par an
le marché international est porteur
fabriquer des produits dopants ont ça
coûte pas cher du tout mais ce sont des
molécules qui sont assez faciles à
synthétiser et leur vendre évidemment ça
apporte des bénéfices assez colossaux on
retombe pas dans le problème du marché
noir de l'art de la drogue internet à
moderniser les moyens de
s'approvisionner
on peut acheter des anabolisants pour
2500 francs
les autorités de l'augmenter les
contrôles mais le trafic informatique
rend encore plus difficile le
démantèlement des filières à l'étranger
maintenant la principale information
nous vient encore d'irlande du nord où
les trois enfants brûlés vifs dans
l'incendié de leur pavillon dimanche
dernier ont été portés en terre
ce qui n'empêche pas les orangistes de
rester mobilisés apporte des tonnes
à quelques kilomètres à peine du lieu du
drame etienne leenhardt
combien faudra-t-il encore d'image comme
celle ci combien faudra-t-il de petits
cercueils blancs de familles en deuil et
de parents en larmes avant qu'enfin l'on
se décide à faire la paix l'irlande du
nord ce matin se regarder et se faisait
sans doute un peu honte
richard marks et jason brûlées vives
dans leur sommeil après qu'un cocktail
molotov et embraser leur maison ont été
enterrés aujourd'hui ils sont les
dernières victimes de cette règle
sectaire anachronique et absurde selon
laquelle les enfants d'un catholique
n'ont rien à faire dans un quartier
protestant et la victoire de ceux qui
les ont tués c'est de voir ces familles
catholiques voisine de la maison des
garçons qui derrière le quartier pour ne
plus jamais y revenir
paradoxalement avait-on penser cette
tragédie devrait mettre un terme aux
affrontements de portadown mais de
nouveaux incidents se sont produits la
nuit dernière entre les forces de
l'ordre et deux à trois mille
irréductibles protestantes orangistes
qui exige depuis neuf jours de pouvoir
parader dans le quartier catholique de
la vie après la mort des trois enfants
faut-il partir quand il restait à plus
de parts appuyé d'injures les
protestants se déchirent est même entré
hier après midi
situation confuse étendue dont on ne
sait si elles annoncent leur chant du
cygne ou la promesse d'un nouvel
embrasement en russie c'est la décision
historique du fonds monétaire
internationale d'accorder une aide de
plus de 26 milliards de dollars étalé
sur deux ans contre l'octroi de ces
prêts la banque mondiale exige une
réduction de moitié du déficit
budgétaire russe
il a fallu deux semaines de difficiles
tractations pour conclure cet accord qui
devrait permettre d'éviter une
dévaluation du rouble en russie
aujourd'hui
boris elstine a fait savoir qu'il ne se
représenterait pas à l'élection
présidentielle en l'an 2000 en france à
un premier départ de feu important près
de à loos en périphérie de marseille le
feu a été attisé par un fort mistral
mais heureusement les pompiers ont
réussi à le maîtriser
six canadair étaient mobilisés ainsi que
120 hommes des marins pompiers de
marseille
et puis
- dans l'hérault c'est le pilote d'un
petit bombardier qui a été tué quand son
appareil s'est écrasé près de lodève en
luttant lui aussi contre un départ de
feu le mondial de pétanque à marseille
une compétition qui existe maintenant
depuis 37 ans cette année dix mille
joueurs et 90000 spectateurs car lille
marie et gérard galian il était
aujourd'hui pour les huitièmes et les
quarts de finale le but du jeu c'est de
tt le bouchon comprenez placer la boule
le plus près possible
voici donc les quarts de finale du
mondial à pétanque j'ai bien dit
pétanque ne pas faire de confusion
c'est quoi la différence enfin je crois
ça lui donnait un jeune nordiste pas de
gaz donc il faut se méfier du
vocabulaire
n'allez pas dire à un tireur qu'il vient
de pointer caveau point-e c'est que vous
tirez pas d'un côté s'est ajustée s'est
joué vers le bouchon a retiré ses
chemins pour mission de pousser la boule
qui accueille qui après des buts qu'ils
marquent le point
dix mille joueurs participent à la
compétition des joueurs venus de 17 me
la pétanque est un sport qui fait de
plus en plus d'adeptes
aujourd'hui à bull a changé nous avons
les femmes par exemple ce sont des choix
ce boulot fantastique
vous avez 25 à 32 % sur les dix mille
joueurs qui sont des femmes et des
jeunes filles
c'est merveilleux de voir jouer savez si
ça marche dans le football on a vu
comment réaliser ces dames
ça marche aussi d'aller voler demain
c'est la finale il ne reste que des
conflits en dise on ne peut imaginer ici
que le vainqueur ne soit pas marseillais
on appris aujourd'hui la mort de jean
paredes le comédien français c'était un
ce week-end à l'âge de 76 ans que jean
paredes avait fait partie de la troupe
de jean louis barrault et joué dans
nombreuses comédies comme la vie
parisienne et la cuisine des anges
on l'avait vu aussi dans fanfan la
tulipe au cinéma il préférait le théâtre
les francofolies à la rochelle elles ont
commencé hier soir avec une première
cette année la présence de michel sardou
chanteur populaire s'il en est est le
pari a été gagné avec près de 5000
spectateurs ce qui ne fut pas le cas en
revanche d'une autre innovation des
francofolies une fête techno baptisé les
francophonies éric perrin et christophe
vignal
c'est la soirée des premières à la
rochelle
pour la première fois en 14 ans les
francofolies reçoivent michel sardou
pour la première fois on a installé à la
demande du chanteur déchets sur la
grande place
du coup certains sceptiques craignent et
un concert froid voire distant il n'en
fut rien bien au contraire à sa manière
michel sardou soigne son public
puis les armes éclairé aux bougies du
allez pas
denis
m
et c'est sans doute là la force d'un
chanteur populaire les spectateurs
finissent toujours par se reconnaît moi
je vais faire beaucoup
je pense que le public fait partie du
spectacle donc c'est bien qu'il soit
englobé dans les dents les lumières il
aime ça des as
il a mis être vu aussi
à
en
en défonçant les barmes a besoin
m
seb n est pas là
s'en vient
pas blues ni jazz ni rock changement
d'ambiance pour une autre première aux
francofolies une nuit techno et pour se
mettre dans l'ambiance le plus simple
c'est de poser des questions enfin
d'essayer
techno trance que pense donc michel
sardou le chanteur des bals populaires
de cette nouvelle forme de l'usc
gmx fait pas dj climat remixer des
chansons moi je me reconnais c'est même
pas évident mais s'étaient formées la
même s'il fait la ligne mélodique avec
un pied de batterie je m'en fous l'idée
est bonne
bon faut oser il ose un peu là dedans
ils sentent libres avis aux amateurs aux
on attend donc une nuit techno spécial
sardou avec un remix ou ce trip hop
intitulé ne m'appelez plus jamais france
hall et la fête continue ce soir partout
en france avec les fameux bal du 14
juillet certains avaient pris les
devants dès hier soir comme dans cette
caserne des sapeurs-pompiers du 10e
arrondissement à paris
des balles qui s'annonce un peu
particulier dans l'ambiance de la
victoire de l'équipe de france de
football vous le voyez et vous serez
également nombreux à vous rendre sur le
champ de mars à paris ce soir pour
assister aux spectacles et aux feux
d'artifice de jean michel jarre sophie
mais elle l'est mathieu d'anjou
on en suivit la répétition hier faire
exploser le ciel de paris à coups de
rythmique batterie clavier de son
synthétique
jean michel jarre l'abonné des 14
juillet me promettez plus un insert
purement électronique car milan perd des
foyers sur des kilomètres de câbles
l'équivalent d'un millier de machines à
laver qui tournerait tout en même temps
cette performance se tiendra jusqu'à
minuit au pied de la tour eiffel
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a plus besoin
d'expliquer la musique électronique
quand j'ai commencé c'était une manière
de faire de la musique aujourd'hui je
pensais le genre le plus populaire de la
planète
c'est à dire que la musique électronique
c'est pas seulement la techno c'est
beaucoup d'autres choses
et pour le prouver jean michel jarre
partage sa scène avec des musiciens de
tous les univers dj cam claude monet à
paulo faure fortes y était il ya komuro
une super star japonaise 101 millions de
disques vendus
cette longue midi s'achèvera sur un feu
d'artifice devrait aussi permettre de
célébrer une dernière fois la victoire
des bleus et de rebondir sur ce
formidable engouement du public une
nouvelle solidarité qui on aimerait y
croire
changera peut-être certaines mentalités
avant la coupe du monde
le drapeau vert blanc rouge les
considéré par beaucoup comme quelque
chose de ringard pour beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup de gens et à la limite était
devenu petit à petit et bien d'une
certaine manière l'étendard du front
national c'est très regrettable
il était temps pour le récupère et
aujourd'hui nous avons tous récupéré
c'est ce qu'on va essayer on va essayer
d'enfoncer tout le soir du 14 juillet ce
soir le champ de mars se transformera en
une gigantesque boîte de nuit un million
de spectateurs si tout va bien un
million maintenant on a l'habitude voile
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle le titre principal les bleus
une nouvelle fois à l'honneur
aujourd'hui mais cette fois à l'elysée à
la traditionnelle garden party
l'ambiance était totalement foot et
jacques chirac s'est affichée comme le
premier les supporters un président de
la république très modéré dans ses
critiques à l'égard du gouvernement dans
un sens vous avez rendez vous avec que
sophie davant pour la météo attention au
vent il ya beaucoup de feux d'artifice
qui était prévu dans les bouches du
rhône y qui sont supprimés à cause du
mistral
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur france 2 je vous dis à demain à 20
heures
m
les hommes